is it really surprising that the most
powerful man in the world should be a
figure of controversy we as a population
on this planet have been looking for a
savior we're talking about a being whose
very existence you're not telling us the
truth
challenges our own sense of priority in
the universe human beings have a
horrible track record of following
people with great power an absolute
power corrupts absolutely hey maybe he's
just a guy trying to do the right they
know better now don't that ones don't
come from Hell beneath the world has
been so caught up with what he can do
that no one has asked what he should
that's how it starts the fever the rage
the feeling of powerlessness that turns
good men
cruel
tell me do you plead
hey youtubers is Charlie so surprised
not surprised Warner Brothers decided
because of the leak they'd release the
trailer officially so this is gonna be a
breakdown to that so there are a couple
big cities that we'll visit in the film
to obviously really notable ones Gotham
and metropolis here we see a statue of
Superman
this doesn't pick up too much further
after the last Man of Steel movie not
not a whole lot of time has passed it's
going to directly address what happened
in that film how much Superman tore the
city up some of the voiceovers you hear
our Holly Hunter she's playing a senator
we hear Lex Luthor in a voiceover the
Alfred voiceover at the end is actually
more telling about how fear can corrupt
good men he's talking about both
Superman and Lex Luthor what you think
is interesting Lex Luthor is always more
fun when he's not just like a
straight-up villain there's still be a
lot of the classic dynamics in there but
he's gonna be a tech billionaire
confronted with the idea of this alien
godlike creature on earth clearly he's
not gonna be super happy about what's
going on Batman on the other hand Ben
Affleck's Batman is also gonna be really
pissed off the whole theme of the
trailer is everybody hates Superman you
can see in this scene here you know a
bunch of people worship him but because
he can't be everywhere all at the same
time people are starting to get pissed
at him you're supposed to be a god why
can't you fix everything here's a pretty
cool shot of him disabling what looks
like a Russian rocket it could be a
warhead it could be a satellite it could
be a spaceship there's actually a Man of
Steel Easter Egg for Wayne Enterprises a
Wayne Enterprises satellite just got
taken out whenever the Kryptonians came
to earth this is really interesting
because you see a bunch of soldiers
wearing Superman symbol patches on their
arms either it's a police task force
that's been trying to help him or it's a
bunch of fanatics to think that they're
serving him Superman isn't one to court
that kind of attention so clearly he's
gonna be really uncomfortable with
people treating him like a god and here
we finally see the graffiti false god
this is like public opinion slowly
turning against him the interesting
thing is he's never supported the idea
that he is a god or even called himself
that
angry Bruce Wayne this is gonna be a
slightly older Bruce Wayne than we've
seen before or forty something if you
haven't read Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns comic book it's actually it's
not a great Superman book it's a great
Batman story not so great for Superman
though that story inspires the tone of
Batman vs Superman is well
a lot of visual elements they didn't
directly take the plot or anything it's
a complete adaptation so it's it's
entirely Zack Snyder's story that he's
changed a little bit here's a good shot
of the Batsuit finally we saw this in
the teaser last night this question mark
is a nice Easter Egg for the Riddler
probably gonna appear in one of the
films at some point here's a good shot
of the Batmobile in action it actually
looks a lot like the Arkham Knight
Batmobile
with the really hardcore battle-ready
Batmobile not quite a tank like the
tumbler a little more agile this is
actually the best full-on shot of Ben
Affleck in costume that we've seen so
far you definitely see a lot of Frank
Miller's Batman costume in there and Ben
Affleck did get jacked for the role
here's a better shot of him in like the
The Dark Knight Returns armor he's also
using a vocoder to affect his voice I
think that's an answer to the Christian
Bale Batman voice that everyone's just
started to make fun of it's gotten so
ridiculous that's been parodied so much
that I totally agree with them that they
should not try and replicate it it is
just too silly now do you bleed you will
there's a lot of theories that Batman
might be involved in the synthesis of
kryptonite in this film at some point
kryptonite will become a part of this
universe but Zack Snyder said before the
first Man of Steel movie that kryptonite
did not exist on earth there are only
three ways to hurt Superman one you can
be stronger than him like it in the case
of the other Kryptonians two you can use
magic which we haven't seen in this
universe yet and three you can use
kryptonite which we also haven't seen
yet of those three things kryptonite is
just the most logical you know I think
that'll will flow from some of the the
terraforming logic that they set up in
Man of Steel I know a lot of people are
wondering like where Aquaman a lot of
the other characters are in this film
supposedly they're gonna have incredibly
minor roles it's mostly gonna be Batman
Superman and gal gadot's Wonder Woman
because this is just a teaser trailer
what I think is gonna happen is I think
the next trailer will reveal gal gadot
usually they save a lot for like the
second and third trailers so expect a
new trailer in like another month or two
so let me know what you guys think of
the movie so far based on this footage I
think it'll be interesting I mean really
what we'll have to see more footage
before we can pass judgement but I'm
still doing an arrow and flash Q&A
there's a new flash trailer that's
totally crazy so be sure to subscribe to
get that also a lot of Game of Thrones
and some more daredevil coming this
weekend in case you guys haven't seen it
I posted a whole bunch of Star Wars
trailers so click here to watch the next
Star Wars Episode seven
trailer like three four ten more times
and click here for the latest Star Wars
Battlefront 3 trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you